relationships with a narcissist can you
describe what that side is like there's
no such thing as equal with a narcissist
they hate adult to adult communication
that's no good they're a kind of a God
in their own universe so in
transactional analysis terms they don't
do adult adult vulnerable communication
they do parent-child communication so
they're very hierarchical and for them
vertical and standing over you that's
equal when you shift it they get
stressed just by asking for decent human
behavior you asking them to be a
reasonable adult to calm down to come
and have a chat to go to counseling to
fix the problem you'll induce
narcissistic injury is one of the things
that they do threatening it's one of the
nine traits from the DSM it's extremely
bullying and threatening behavior in
complex post-traumatic stress disorder
terms we call this a narcissistic
personality disorder is a fight-forn
response so their way of acting in the
world is to bully love out of people
they're emotional terrorists they've
gone to the Head love me or else submit
to me or else
the true Geordie podcast